One of the most important things to do for EMFs, when I look at some suggestions,
like recalls, it seems like a lot inexpensive. Also, what's the point of turning off your Wi-Fi?
If your neighbor's Wi-Fi signals are also zooming through your house.
If EMFs were a significant problem for our cancer, would you have come up with that when you do
our cheek swabs? Yes and no, because EMFs are rarely the cause of a cancer. They are
causes of other ill effects in your body. They can be disruptive in all body functions in all
cancers, but they're rarely the primary cause. What can you do about EMFs?
Well, that's very difficult because you're right. If you do turn off your Wi-Fi,
you still have your neighbor's Wi-Fi that you could pick up if they had their password.
However, it's the farther you are away from the source, the less
effect it's going to have on your body. I've had people that were really highly sensitive to EMFs,
and these were more so when I was seeing a lot more live patients. People that have
some chronic live issues and chronic mold issues, many times it's cross the blood braid barrier
and it's caused an inflammatory process in the braid. If you have an inflammation in the braid,
whether it's due to due from lime or mold or post-concussive syndrome or braid tumors,
do you have any reason to have inflammation in the braid that may or may have not
have caused what's called microglial primate and you can watch my video on
neuroinflammation. I think I have several blog posts on that on braid inflammation.
I will help you understand neuroglial primate. These people with that are much more sensitive to EMFs,
because your neural tissue is going to be more affected by EMFs than, let's say,
a breast tumor. That's going to be the greater concern for EMF sensitivity issues.
Forever, you also have that genetic, that CAG, whatever N-A-G, I think it is,
that if you have a lot of defects on that gene, you're going to be more sensitive to EMFs as well.
So I wouldn't noted that in your genetic review. But if you have brain inflammation of any kind,
special neuroglial primate, you're going to be more sensitive to EMFs and I've had people in that
category before that have used those sheets. So take in this sheet because these are fairly large when
you open them up and have pinned them up in their bedroom. So pinned them up on the wall behind
their bed, pinned them up on each wall of their bed room to block EMFs at least while they're sleeping.
And one gal who's developing dementia, early age dementia, this is what I had her do.
And I think it slowed the dementia, that's all what you could really hope for for dementia. So
have this, she has one on her bed. Well, why would you do this? Because it's a groudy cheek. I know,
but with the fibers in there, it blocks EMFs too. So yeah, that gets to me costly. This is that would
probably be the less costly fix. There's other things that you could do with home, home, the static,
the static products. But that gets expensive too. So like here's the whole whole EMF thing, but
I didn't turn it up. So you could look about whole home EMF block edge thing, this thing right here.
Then we have on our website, not have very many people buy that, but this you connect to your wire
it's like $1,300 actually saves you electricity because it saves the surge on all your
electric products. So it does paint for itself in a couple years from your electrical savings.
But that's that's forward dirty electricity. So that's not going to
protect you against the neighbor's wifi and things. So it does, you know, how many things can you
do before you go broke in this thing? So there's there's some things you just can't do. So I suggest
just take more comments and approach. I still think it's beneficial turn off your wifi at night while
you're sleeping while you don't need that. Get your cell phone away from you while you're sleeping,
put it in the other room, put it in one of our little bags, you know, those little bags made out
of this material cost you very little. So, you know, the Faraday cages are your best bet for
things like that. You know, like this person, you made baits that tried to make a semi Faraday cage out
of her bedroom with these sheets. So you just have to have a balance with everything. If you're
going to just go overboard and go crazy about it, then, you know, you're you're getting out of balance.
And just do your best without, you know, causing financial stress in your household.
And emotional stress and anxiety in your own in yourself is awesome. I am also a poor sweater,
poor consult with developer of Theresage. I sit in my 45 minutes at 165. That's interesting.
So higher temperature for a longer period of time.
Is that helped? I'm interested. Does do you sweat a lot more? Is it just the length of time
it's causing you to, you know, have a greater notice. Yes, river sweat. Oh, river sweat.
Yeah, I think there's a dance troupe by that name.
Well, this wasn't it. No, I would say that's different.